guru a would sell a 2 000 product and
then
affiliates for that would sell their pr
they would sell
that person's product and then sell a
product that they previously sold for
two thousand dollars they'll throw it in
as a bonus for free
if you buy through my affiliate link
from from guru a i was seeing my sales
letter
a lot of the stuff that i wrote for for
clients a lot of it was
original stuff being copied verbatim on
other
products for other the completely
different you know
information products that's when i start
to realize
okay this is this is not not good and
then
ladies and gentlemen welcome to
coffeezilla today we have a very special
guest we have michael forton
michael you are a legend in the
copywriting community
uh you're sort of a historian of the
copywriting world you know
so much and your arc is a very
interesting one because you've achieved
wild successes in the copywriting
community and
at the same time your views on this
space have evolved
michael give me an introduction to how
you got started in this industry
and sort of some of the highlights of
your career
sure so um at the very beginning of my
career i was in sales
and i had a excuse me i had a
tremendous fear of rejection so i wanted
to find a way to get
prospects to come to me rather than me
to them and what i decided to do was
rather than knocking on doors i was in
the insurance business back then rather
than knocking on doors and getting doors
slammed in my face i decided to write
sales letters and then send it to people
and get
people calling me to set up an
appointment and lo and behold that's
when i discovered this thing called
copywriting um fast forward a little bit
so i started working for cosmetic
surgeons and i started to write
copy for infomercials later on
infomercials for hair transplant
doctors i created the full full display
displayed ads
sales letters as well and newsletters
and whatnot and
that kind of evolved to the
other professional services to other uh
doctors lawyers chiropractors and so on
and then
finally reached the internet marketing
community and then i became
pretty much well known in the internet
marketing community uh from that point
on
so you ran a uh a board
as well yes in addition to it was pretty
popular
like copywriter board what was it called
again yeah copyright sport
so essentially what i wanted to do was i
wanted to get more business and at that
time what i
decided to do was i i created a board
for two reasons i one
one of the reasons was uh i would do
critiques free critiques on a
i would just take a website from a
client that or somebody i really want to
have as a client
and then i would do a copywriting
critique and i would post it on my board
and uh with the hope that the client
would see it but if not some other
clients or some people would see it and
say oh this guy knows what he's doing
and so
they would hire me and i would basically
get more business from that point on
and then basically that board kind of
exploded i had other copywriters joining
doing the same thing
everybody kind of sharing knowledge
sharing critiques critiquing other
people's work
uh and then they had quite a quite a big
following we had several thousands of
tens of thousands of of members
uh and then uh after one point where i
just like
the the egos and the uh and the whole
i know the things that you talk about
often kind of grew out of uh in ottawa
so i decided just to close everything
down
i want to explore that moment when uh i
mean
it's kind of you say it you know so
casually because it's in the past but
you shut down a board with you know tens
of thousands of active members which is
pretty
wild so at that point some
disillusionment
had happened but right what what what
was that for you because you know i'm
always on here and i'm just passionately
saying what i think copywriting is or
isn't or whatever whether it's predatory
whether
whether it's not you know it's easy for
people to
kind of dismiss me i'm a hater right i
just don't like when people make money
i don't like that uh people are just
balling out of control and i'm just i
hate capitalism i hate puppies and i
hate bald eagles probably
i mean they don't know but probably but
you're someone who's a little harder to
dismiss because you're
a really a legend in the space uh we
talked about this but you were the first
person
we talked about this off the record but
you were the first person to break a
million dollar sales day in copywriting
is that right
you're the first person the roger
bannister of copywriting
yes it's it's it's a neat label i was
given to
uh i was given that by some other
marketer and i just stuck with me and
said oh that's great that's like
because here's the thing when i wrote
that sales letter it was a long sales
letter for
a course what was it called pardon me
what was it called the course
oh it was traffic secrets which is
actually now owned by russell bronson
but it used to be from
john reese at that time in 2004
2003 to yeah 2004 and uh
basically it became the very first
million dollar day in the internet
marketing space and of course that
record has been broken many many times
multiple times
have many magnitudes more since
uh so uh but basically i was the first
copywriter to do that and that kind of
made me become known in this industry
because of that
million dollar day right and so and so
my point with bringing that up is
not to just blow smoke at you but it's
also to say that
you're someone who's been in the space
well respected
and you're now writing about how this
industry
is really predatory what changed in your
life that you're like went from i mean
it's probably pretty hard to say that
something that
you know was pulling in a million
dollars a day could be
it's hard to speak out against that you
know what i mean there's a lot of
cognitive dissonance there of like
oh here's something making me a ton of
money but i also think it's bad
i see a lot of people really struggle
with that and fight against it and like
oh they just put their head in the sand
they don't want to see what this
industry
is doing to people but you speak openly
about it about you know
you knowing about people who have
literally mortgaged their house to buy
courses is that right yes what was that
change for you how did that happen
well it's not an overnight process it
was a gradual
process over a period of time because
here's the thing whenever i was working
as a copywriter i was hired as a
copyright for a lot of these internet
marketers
and sometimes i would be asked to write
copy for
projects that i really wasn't happy
about i wasn't
really i didn't find it i didn't feel
good about
so i started refusing clients i started
to refund clients i
i'd start to to not take out any more
clients that that was one part of it
then the second part of it was do you
remember what those clients were
selling i mean like give us a bought
like an example i i you know
there's it's hard to i don't want to i
don't want to mention any names but
basically it's like
you know it's like selling a course uh
on
how to make money which is basically how
to make your own course on how to make
money
on on how to sell another course how to
make so it's basically a ponzi scheme
um and and so you're you're literally
selling a
an internet marketing course teaching
other people about internet marketing
which is about how do they create their
own internet marketing course
um add the infant item and and
that's kind of what it just left me a
bad taste in my mouth and i think
your your interview with jim claire was
just absolutely phenomenal was beautiful
because he
he said a lot of the things that that i
spoke about that was on my mind as well
and
i think that um like i said it was a
gradual it was an evolution
and throughout that entire process uh
when i was writing copy for a lot of
these sales letters i was seeing my
sales letter
a lot of the stuff that i wrote for for
clients a lot of it was
original stuff being copied verbatim on
other
products for other the completely
different you know uh
information products that's when i
started to realize
okay this is this is not not good and
then basically what i did was i wrote a
there was there was a kind of a um a
trend going on in 2004 2005 2006 called
the you know there was a lot of reports
coming out the death of the death of
affiliate marketing the death of
pay-per-click advertising the death of
this and that that and i came out with
one
yeah it was clickbaity i admit that but
it's called the death of the sales
letter and the reason why
is because i really believe that these
long sales letters
especially to kind of just just to get
the sale
uh it well either i i thought it was
dying i believe it was and i
i actually do believe it still uh isn't
uh in the process of of of dying
because i there there's a lot of sales
that is out there still but we are now
more into a
funnel where people are being educated
through the process until they finally
buy a product or service
uh anyways the point though is at that
time i i saw that but i also was
disillusioned by the fact that a lot of
the sales letters that i seen were just
copies of what i was
writing right so um and
and that that led to a few other
situations where for example um
my wife at that time had cancer and she
was
dealing with uh chemotherapy and all
that stuff
and uh you know we came we came across a
lot of stuff in
in that space that just made us you know
cringe
uh people who actually literally uh
told my wife to get off of chemo i'm
basically killing my wife with chemo and
all that
yeah and so so
she wrote actually a report called
internet marketing sins and we were
talking a lot about
or she was talking a lot about uh some
of the stuff that she saw
that was uh just not um
you know kosher not not necessarily uh
the best or the most ethical practices
in our industry
and and i think that there's a lot of
there's a lot of
things that contributed to that but at
the same time my views kind of
merged where i said you know what this
is just not the way this you know
the things i don't think that that's
really proper way to
you know do business on the internet um
and
i think that a lot of you see a lot of
now internet marketers who have kind of
evolved to become more service oriented
or more sas
oriented software so they kind of clean
up their acts a lot i think it was
that's a good thing
and i myself included i mean i i sell
services now i do seo and
all that uh but at the same time uh
i'm seeing like like for example when i
saw when i re i watched some of your
videos
steven the ads that come up
[Laughter]
oh yeah they proved my point oh my gosh
and i think that
that kind of industry is uh it's
sickening and
and the reason i i think it's sickening
is because when i hear the stories of
people
falling for kind of these products and
services products generally
that are promising them you know the
world
it's uh fine if you if you want to if
you have a really good product that's
valuable and it's actually teaching
skills
you know for example how to create an
actual business how to do market
research and how to
you know uh hire staff how to manage
staff how to grow your business that way
the accounting the financing side of
stuff right fine but when you're
starting to uh
you know show you know here's how to
make a million dollars and here's my
lamborghinis in the background and
here's my
my jet plane uh so new now you're no
longer selling skills you're no longer
selling information you're selling
dreams and hopes
and you're preying on people who are
broke and sick and
and you know they this is just crazy
well here's the sad part i mean i think
you know this but
some of the things that are the most
disgusting or
they promise you know oh we'll carry
cancer we'll cure your
you know uh financial cancer whatever
whatever like we'll make a million
dollars
those are the things that sell the best
unfortunately it's uh
yeah a lot of times the bigger claims
you know
as long as you give some pseudo proof
right you give some
pseudo testimonials or whatever people
buy into it
that's what gets people to you know have
the ad spend to spend like they do
it's no small wonder that most of the
things
that you see in that space right now are
kind of
you know over the top lambos make a
million dollars
uh cure your cancer whatever it is
really disgusting but it sounds like
by the way i'm sorry to hear about your
wife um it sounds like
your wife's you know cancer diagnosis
was a huge part of that
yes for you to connect what you were
were selling with the people at the
other end of
that sales letter yeah um
so my wife went through uh
first of all at that time in her life in
our lives my mom passed away of cancer
and uh we took care of her before she
did we actually set up a hospice in
our house and we kind of took a back
seat from the business uh because at
that time
you know health was more important um
and as that was going
on um it was uh
incredibly um you know
it was it was a way for me to kind of
realize
that this this is not you know this is
not a business that i want to be in this
is not really something that i feel
comfortable with
uh and admittedly i have written sales
letters for
a lot of these products and and i think
that
um you know we need to have people like
you
like you to to shine a light on this
industry not for the purpose of teaching
the people who are doing this stuff
but for the people who are buying this
stuff sadly because i think that people
need to be educated on on the scams that
out there and that's one of the reasons
why i don't mention any names
um i think you were interviewed on a
jordan harbinger show and jordan said
something that was perfectly well said
he said we want to focus on the
behaviors on this
on the scams rather than the scammers
because we want people to be
able to realize or to recognize these
without
you know putting specific spotlights on
people for one reason
and another reason is well first of all
if i mention
if i mention scammer a that means no
this guru who is really scammer b
is oh he's fine then because you
mentioned scammer and then he should be
you know should be okay
and that was one of the reasons why i
don't i didn't mention any names and
in sylvie when my my late wife when she
wrote internet marketing since a report
back then
she said the same thing i'm not going to
mention any names because i really want
to focus on the behaviors
and the the scams rather than the
scammers
yeah i think jordan harbinger was really
wise when he said that and i think your
wife's really wise for doing that
um i do because i do agree that it is
a pattern of behavior i mean you do see
the same thing repeated over and over
again
as you said these people aren't exactly
um
innovating like there is just this sort
of repetitive thing that just keeps
going on
and it's this endless cycle of just like
perpetual pitch fests
uh i think that was a word you used in
one of your one of your
um articles you were a part of those
pitch fest for some time
take me behind the scenes of what that
is like
so many people don't know because now a
lot of it's done online but
the seminar game was huge the seminar
game was where it was all at
it still actually happens you know at
like tony robbins events
the 10x event right the you know that's
the grant cardone version
um right what is the pitch fest
who goes and what what's the big deal
what's the big deal with selling a few
two thousand five thousand ten thousand
dollar
courses why is that a bad thing what did
you see if i were to go to a seminar
where i'm actually walking away with
real skills that i can
take home create a business with
uh and and or sell a product or service
and of course not selling a product on
how to make money
but but basically a legitimate skill
that i can learn from a seminar then the
seminar is valuable
uh but when you go to a seminar where
you've got speaker after speaker after
speaker after speaker
selling their one thousand two thousand
three thousand five thousand dollar
course one after the other
and you're seeing people literally uh
maxing out their credit cards in the
back of the room uh
i you know i've heard stories of of of
people remortgaging their houses for
these courses it's
it's yeah and then and declaring
bankruptcy
and um it's sad because
i think what's what's going on is
there's there's uh
there's a mentality of people who are
going to these seminars it's kind of
this
um you know i'm not a psychologist by
any stretch of the imagination but i
i know that there is kind of a mentality
that people i think mike winit who
who when he speaks on the entrepreneur
he talks about these seminars where when
you're around a lot of people and you're
basically
you know everybody's waving their hands
you feel like you're left out and i
think that mentality kind of pervades a
lot and
sadly uh it's it's that's kind of the
thing that really stuck to me is like
you know i can't believe that people
would go to that extreme
um number one um and and number two
um when i hear stories of what goes on
behind the scenes like for example
you've got a lot of seminars who are
pretty legitimate uh i i've spoken at a
few of them but i also spoken at some of
these pitch fest which is
unfortunate but some of these uh
seminars are really focused on trying to
maximize as much as you possibly can
from the
seminar attendees and i think you
mentioned this in one of your videos
where you said you know it's like
extracting every
possible penny from those those seminar
attendees
and uh sadly that's what kind of these
seminar
companies do and i've you know i've
heard of stories of
seminar companies hiring telemarketers
who would go after either the attendees
prior or after the seminar
and you know the the whole boiler room
telemarketer
type of or process where basically the
question is how many you know how much
money do you have left on your credit
card and basically that's the part
that's the price of our product or this
is the price of our coaching program or
whatever the case is right right uh
sadly
yeah no this was this was one of the
accusations i think in the ftc complaint
letter against
um the nudge defendants they were a big
seminar firm that i believe that uh
dean graziosi used a lot of these uh
people
used i think robert hertrovich was
involved in one of these seminar
companies for real estate
they would ask on the phone though that
was like one of the things how much
money do you have
oh wow look at that that actually just
happens to be the price of the course
but i do think i i want to address that
mentality you talked about i think
that's really important that
mentality of the sucker the fleece
the the person who's getting kind of
like the wool pull
over their eyes because in a way i think
okay
that is something that needs to be
addressed like people's
need to be led or whatever oh there's
another side of this too which is
cultivated though
by the pitch man by
the uh scammer i would say or by the
guru
and that's this that mentality is this
you need a mentor see you need someone
to walk you
a to z for how to be successful
otherwise you'll never be successful
it's implicit in all of their stories
their story is i was a loser
then i found guru x or whatever or
system
i found out the one trick and then i'm
going to save you all the time because
i'll be
that person for you you saw this really
re-emerge i guess it had always been
there but with tai lopez he was the
mentor guy you need a mentor
he was like the one to do with the
biggest on youtube a few years back and
now
everyone does it but don't you think
that that
is a part of the system right to
reinforce
these belief systems that makes you need
to buy because of course if
i need a mentor well man where's the
mentor oh
he's right up on stage willing to sell
to me right
um it's kind of funny that you mentioned
that because uh
not only are people you know first of
all
99.99 of everything that you need to
know
to do very well is available online
right now you know there's a tool called
google there's a tool called youtube
and there are there might be some
insider information there might be some
things that people have
done tried and that is not very well
known you know the insider information
and i agree that's perfectly fine
but it's when people are being told when
they fail
well it's not it's not the information's
fault it's your fault
it's either then try harder or maybe you
didn't try this other product maybe you
should buy my other
product no that you failed with that too
let me let me sell you this other
product that will get you
to you know so basically you're
basically a mentor
to make me buy more products you're
really basically a salesperson that's
what you really are not a mentor
uh to me a mentor i mean first of all
for example what i do now i sell
advisory services and i advise
corporations on our professional
services firms on
on their marketing from seo to
copywriting to website development and
all that stuff
but they're paying me a fee to do that
rather than me selling them the the
dream that they're going to make a lot
of money or they're going to become
you know they're going to become a
public company in in
2021 or whatever um and
but but then again see that's the thing
that a lot of these
gurus or these mentors do is that they
say you need a mentor
i think that there is a there's a
there's a there's a valid
reason behind having somebody to help
you but it's the price point that it's
attached to that
and and the whole mentality behind that
that just drives me nuts
um i have i'm i'm part of a couple of
of groups they're mentorship groups that
cost me
ten dollars a month you know they're
basically uh a group of people that we
just you know
shoot the breeze and we share ideas and
we share kind of this insider
information
but it's just a group of it's like an
association it's no different than an
association
there's no secret cabal of this you know
these all these
people that are noticeable i mean really
yeah
we talked about that that the ten
thousand dollars a month twenty thousand
dollars a month
these uh these really high price the
millionaire uh
circle the million dollar circle the
dragon 100
the advisory boards yeah how many people
from those boards how many people
so so let me back up how many people who
have joined those
have truly become successful so you have
for example a lot of these guys who are
using you haven't heard the famous story
of elon musk joining the dragon 100
so you've got a lot of these guys who
have sales letters with with uh case
studies but a lot of these case studies
are either for
other products that they've they've
created or for something completely
different
um and and you know sometimes it's about
the actual product they're selling
you know they're not they're not i'm i'm
going to teach you this system how to
become successful
i'm i'm getting fired up here i'm going
to tell you this product going to become
successful and i'm going to take the
testimonial and i'm going to use that to
tell you how to sit it's like
it's a ponzi scheme selling a ponzi
scheme anyways
i'm backing up but the point though is
and it's something that you've mentioned
in one of
your videos you talk about like for
example amazon where
eight percent make as much money as
a fry cook right um
and so that's the exact point is that if
if you're going to sell this thousand
ten thousand dollar course
how many of those people actually make
enough money
many times over to justify that that
investment that expense
right oh but it's an investment in
yourself it's an investment it's your
success
oh yeah the best investment is an
investment in yourself
how much are you worth right that's like
that's the common uh
refrain and that's and that's the that's
the thing that i hate
i think what i personally hate about
this industry is the whole concept of
this
neuro-linguistic programming how you can
use
psychological tactics to hypnotize your
audience into
you know because we tell like for
example here's the thing
um jim claire talked about stories you
know you can
tell stories do sell telling a story but
telling a real story
is you know trying to put something in
its best possible light that's that's
great
but when you start to make up fake
stories with fake names with
fake backgrounds of this you know and
and that's why i really loved your
interview with jim is that it's it's
that's where it gets really um vomit
inducing
um and and people who follow that and
then when when they find out when they
find out that those stories are not
necessary
oh but but but what he taught me was
true
you know it's the truth behind the
system yeah it's uh it's such
that's such a lie yeah i know people uh
i've heard people try to defend that and
it's it's indefensible when you write a
story
and you know and i think also one rule
to think about your story it's like
if your customer knew what you knew
about your own story
would they still buy the product and
most of the time with all these fake
stores the answer is of course not
a great example is uh this was big a few
years ago
they were selling this this keto
supplement they re-spun it into a lot of
different supplements
where it was a fake story about how
shark tank made its biggest investment
ever into this
pill right it's a total lie this guy
from mit
found this magical pill the sharks were
so excited
whatever and they have a picture of a
guy getting like smiling at the sharks
he's a beard set like he does beard oil
they just like completely took the
picture
lied about it whatever this was sold all
across facebook
yahoo whatever and it did super well and
so people
are swiping the files look how well it's
converted i want to swipe it if you guys
know what swipes are
um probably most of my audience does
swipe files i'm just gonna swipe this
and turn it into a diabetes
thing i'm going to turn this into a
blood sugar medication by the way all
those
offers now are still online um
and it it is so vomit-inducing when you
find out the truth that these are
basically just being used to peddle
snake oil and this whole story this
you know these authorities are being
used to just launder
these shady these shady um pills
so i think i think what you said is
really true it's like that's when it
gets
disgusting but going back to you know
peace
what were you going to say about nlp
because fake stories and nlp are a bit
different
one is like oh i'm going to hypnotize
you into basically
you must buy the product yeah there's
there's in the copyrighting circles
uh when especially when i had my board
um a lot of the people who were
copywriters who were part of the board
at that time were
a lot of them were into nlp
neuro-linguistic programming which
you know tony robbins teaches and all
that big tony robbins thing
but it's it's it's the with this whole
you know this whole secret thing this
whole you know
the flaw of attraction which i which is
what i call it but anyways
the flaw of attraction i love that but i
think that
the whole concept of using nlp is
is a there's it's an umbrella term used
that
a lot of these guys especially in the
in you know they make money business the
how to be uh
healthy and and live a long time
business and the pickup artist
industry it's something that is
pervasive at all those three you know
how i can use nlp
to get you know a woman to come to bed
with me or whatever um but they they use
that in
copy and it and and
i think so you know that i do a lot of
uh
um um i follow a lot of copywriters
online as well and i think the best line
that i've ever heard
was from nick osborne and he has this
whole system called conversational
copywriting and he said something on the
board one time and it caused a lot of
controversy a lot of egos were flared up
he said great great products don't need
copy because they should be able to sell
themselves
you know the copy is basically a channel
it's a
it's a facilitation device here's where
oh here's the information about the
product
here's the button to buy and that's it
you don't have to use
nlp you don't have to use all of these
nights there's
stories are good but you don't have to
use all of this
psychological ninja tactics to get
people to
buy because if you really have to
you know it's it that's kind of telling
it's like right if you have to deceive
someone into buying isn't that saying
all
that needs to be said about what your
product is actually good for
or yeah and and and and so i want to
come back to
you know we're talking about my origins
and all that so one of the things that
happened in the
uh at the time that i wrote john reese's
traffic secrets was
a lot of the circle jerking type of of
of
you know these product launches where a
lot of marketers were launching their
two or three thousand dollar products
and they were promoting and i'll be
coming at they're all affiliates of
other
products and so here's the thing is that
so
so guru a would sell a two thousand
dollar product
and then affiliates for that would sell
their pro they would sell
that person's product and then sell a
product that they previously sold for
two thousand dollars they'll throw it in
as a bonus for free
if you buy through my affiliate link
from from guru a so guru b would sell
you know guru a's product and then sell
you know throw in their their product
that they used to you know people are
like
and then people are still you know they
fell for this and that just it was
sickening to me because i realized like
you just paid two thousand dollars for
the same product from you know from that
guru
um so it became all these this product
launched circle jerking right um
i think it was uh my uh my friend paul
myers who said the internet marketing
industry is a bunch of incestuous
cannibals
which is actually very true
they're all pushing each other's
products they're all you know oh this
guy's great i usually should take blah
blah blah
the reason for that by the way is that
there's a small number of people who are
going to buy
internet marketing courses but those
people are usually
high value and you could there's almost
i don't know if you've heard of this
like in
gambling there's like the people who are
addicted they're called whales
um and they're actually there's this
whole thing in gambling
that's kind of a controversy which is
depending on who does the study
um i did a little research thing on on
gambling depending on who does the study
if it's industry funded they say oh yeah
our whales only make up a tiny minority
of our actual profits
whereas other people are saying no no no
who aren't industry funded say
well actually like 20 to 30 of your
profits are actually just
extracting money from this very tiny
minority of
gamblers i feel like that's really true
of
the self-help space and the uh the space
of
like either health scams or wealth scams
where a tiny minority of people are
literally addicted
to buying these things
do you agree with that i do yeah yeah
sadly unfortunately
um but also at the same time um i mean
here's the thing a lot of the seminars
that i used to either speak at or i was
a guest
at a lot of times you know previous
speakers or people in the industry
because i was a well-known copywriter i
was invited as a guest to a lot of these
seminars
you would see a lot of the same faces
every seminar would be the same people
and i'm thinking to myself
so how how well are you doing now well
we you know we tried this
this thing and it where you know we're
going to find the next thing
the next big thing so they're addicted
it's kind of like a dopamine rush
it's to the next best thing that's going
to make me a lot of money
um and i think you had one time you had
somebody in your
uh on your show that talked about um
a ponzi scheme and they got he got taken
in and then basically now he's on to the
next one but this one is legit though he
had
four yeah for everyone he was wondering
i think five maybe he had
done like puns came after ponzi scheme
i hung up the phone with him i thought
we were done because he shared with me
too
and then as we're leaving the call he
goes oh yeah i have like three others
i'm interested in
and i had to restart the call to
reinterview because i was like oh this
is this is the most insane thing i've
ever heard you're
you're literally addicted to just diving
into these new scams and you don't see
how the
previous scam got you but then there are
people who are
i mean obviously feeding because that's
still important but there are people
feeding into that
by then taking their like their hot list
right the people who just bought their
get rich course
and then shipping them to the next guy
who's going to sell them another get
rich course it isn't that hilarious
but that's that's the whole point
because i look look the fact that you're
not
successful yet or maybe you're not happy
with the level of success oh you made
100 bucks last month okay let me let me
show you this other course
this other product and it's it's you
know it's just the same thing over and
over again and
i i find it sad and i think that
um in 2008 when the recession hit
uh and people were probably at their
most vulnerable at their brokest
and a lot of this came out uh yeah and
it was even
that's that's really when i started to
pull completely back because like look
you're taking advantage uh we've had our
call uh off record right we talked about
the fact that a lot of these guys
take advantage of the the broke the ill
and and the
the the old spirit um there's a there's
a fourth one you know i would say the
horny
you know because the the the pickup
artists uh industry is big
but that's that's not i don't i don't
think that hormones is vulnerability but
i think that being old being broke or
being sick
are vulnerable things and and sadly
these guys prey on those people and
you know i i look at a lot of these um
long copy i think i had i had an
argument with somebody on
twitter i think where this person said
oh yeah it's all you know traffic and
and
leads and nerd you know lead nurturing
and getting people to become
educated in the product before they
actually buy the product that's no
longer a thing we're
those are vanity metrics we're now all
about the sale
and i'm thinking that's that's the
direct mentality direct marketing
mentality where we have to go for the
sales of the long copy
and what do you have to do in order to
get to the sale now you yourself you
said you were
in uh in sales when you first started
out and it was all about pushing numbers
well it's the same thing with this
direct marketing
it's all about getting the sale who
cares about what you're doing what
you're pitching
even if you're lying it's all about
making that sale
and at the end of the game once they get
you know they buy the product they're
all ready to go
and then you've got in the back end
really poor customer service
you've got people who are you know
asking for a refund and a lot of these
guys don't
give out refunds or are they saying oh
it's your fault you're the one you
didn't apply it yet
um um and there's a lot of these gurus
out there who teach
techniques on how to avoid giving
refunds or how to
be you know completely legal but just
you know just enough not to be you know
yeah no you're absolutely right there
are people called the chargeback gurus
and all they do is teach people how to
get less chargebacks
not by selling a better product but by
circumventing the
the banks by making sure you dispute
every single charge back
right because there's never a legitimate
reason well why would
well it's the same thing as in the in
the in that at that time
something that was big that became
really popular was this process called
force continuity
and the force continuity was people
would sell
product a and that would be the whole
focus of product a and then the whole
sales letter would be about product a
but at the end when you have to buy well
to get
product a you have to buy a product b
which is a continuity program
a subscription a subscription um
and so it's it's it's you know there's
columbia house did that right it's kind
of the uh i think there's a name for
it's called negative
negative option billing and it's a it
was a popular method you know
like 10 10 cds for one penny you know
whatever
um but the point though is a lot of
these guys would say well
two things let's say we either hide the
continuity so you would buy the product
not knowing that you just signed up to a
subscription and then trying to cancel
your subscription after it would be like
jumping through fiery hoops that are
this small um
but uh the other one is they say well
let's make the charge
under 30 because when it's 27 or less
it's under the
there was one guru who said the wife's
radar
wow under the wife's radar rule yeah
because
yeah because the fact that an amount
that small
every month will not be as noticeable
so they don't even they literally have
no consideration for anyone
even using these products it's like how
much money can we extract
it's really about extraction from this
person before he
even notices basically that's
essentially what that person's saying
before they notice how many months can
we get away with billing their credit
card
that's so disgusting and
these people again i hate to sound like
a broken record here
but as you said they're vulnerable sick
broken old these people are not not ones
with uh typically
with tons of money in the bank that they
can just afford to spend you're not
ripping off jeff bezos
you know what i mean maybe we'd have a
little less sympathy
typically you're ripping off people who
are i mean if they're asking those
questions they're in a bad space they're
in a bad
about if they find their way to your
scammy newsletter chances are they've
exhausted their other options they're
really kind of looking for last ditch
means and that's where it gets gross to
me is i think well
not only have you decided to rent seek
and just extract money
but you've done it to the most
vulnerable people in our society
and that's and ironically that's the way
they get away with it
because if they were taking on rich
people they'd probably get sued
but you aren't going to get sued by a
poor person
right right i think the the concept of
um when people are told to go to
marketing say well
what should i sell what you know which
you know because a lot of people who are
going into this
business they don't even know what to
sell so rather than saying
well package information together that
is usable that is viable that actually
will help people that will truly help
people
and i mean helping in different aspects
uh
no it's all about money it's all about
well you know you're going after a
market that
sell money making schemes that people
are desperate for making money because
they're
the people are going to buy the product
the most you know and
and sadly uh it becomes this perpetual
cycle that just never stops and and i
i i find it uh sad um
i i again i come back to my point is
that a product that is very good should
be
able to sell itself uh and a lot of the
information a lot of these packages
that are are truly if they're truly
innovative
if they're really you know here here's
the thing a lot of people put would put
products together
information that they've already found
that's already available on the internet
and they'll say well here's the thing
that you're buying products you're
buying information from me that i
actually did all the research for you i
put it all together
and i've lined it up in a step-by-step
process to make it simpler and easier
for you
great so how much is the product 40 no
it's 2 000
are you kidding me yeah so so
that's so the thing is if the
information you so you're paying you're
paying for
yes you're not buying information you're
buying for
uh organization organization research
whatever the case is
but it's no different than buying
because how many books are there on
on on amazon on audible whatever the
case is
of information that's that is truly
great information
but you're buying it from a book that's
only like 30 bucks oh why do i have to
pay three thousand dollars from guru a
or b or c
well the funny thing is and this is the
the whole irony behind a lot of this is
that a lot of
those seminars are directly ripped off
of books
that are ten dollars at you know your
local library
three dollars at half price um half
price books
so you could literally get the same
information that you're getting from dan
lok or whoever
for three dollars you know that the only
difference is the packaging
dan lok's not going to be there in his
suit you're not going to get an ad about
it you're not going to get a bentley you
know a little
virtual tour of his bentley that's the
only difference between his thing and
you know some some some book a lot of
this stuff as you said
is recycled um and that's not even to
name names i mean you could say that
about
really any of these gurus it's a recycle
of recycle of recycle i think when we
talked
you go oh yeah haven't you read you know
i i
my knowledge of get rich quick schemes
goes back a little bit but not as far as
yours does
you were like have you heard of the lazy
man's way to get rich by
john carboat joe carbo joe carp
and i said no what's that about and
you're like oh yeah that was
he was basically doing the how to get
rich
selling how to get rich before it was
ever a thing
like before i mean but before the
internet before anything
so right this is all recycled talk a
little bit about that
um and then i want to talk about your
message to copywriters but talk about
joe carbo's book real quick sure
well so you know joe carpenter the whole
concept of the direct mail business that
started
you know way back and in their their
people who have you know
this is being done for a long long time
um
you've got some of the you know the
original copywriters who started this
entire
business the claude hopkins the john e
kennedy's
uh all these guys from the the turn of
the century and and
uh became very well known advertisers
and advertising
agencies um but that kind of spilled
into
what we saw in the 50s and 60s and even
70s
um a blend of two things one it was a
direct mail
the mail order concept um
you know we we hear about chain letters
well chain letters is kind of the
the the you know the more low level but
if if i
show you how do you start a business how
do you how do you create a business
you know i send you a sale as an actual
sales letter in the direct in
in postal mail and print mail and it
teaches you how to
i'll sell you a system on how to create
a business
and how and basically it's the same
thing that you're doing it's really just
a ponzi scheme in disguise um yeah you
might teach some new stuff
maybe there's some value in it but it's
basically just a ponzi scheme well
direct mail then when the internet
started it was easy to just take that
print letter and slap it onto a web page
and then it became this long sales
letter which was
why direct mail was so inviting
for these guys on the internet to
basically
to do that and that's why i wrote the
death of the sales letter this this
white paper
this manifesto in 2004 because i was
saying
it's you know it's too easy now we have
an extra element in all this which is
the mouse we are able to actually
you know go we are able to actually get
educated on this
i read a sales letter i'm able to go to
other websites and see
uh to get more information about it to
get myself educated about it maybe
there's also a process where you can
teach me about your system maybe do a
drip campaign maybe
tell me a little bit more about what
you're you're doing rather than selling
me the dream and the hopes and the
you know all the the money and the the
flashy stuff
um so so and then so
that was one thing so and that also kind
of uh merged with the whole internet
marketing seminar industry
because back in the 70s it was the biz
op industry selling biz ops from the
stages you've got a lot of these
marketers who are selling
business in a box by the way but yeah
yeah it's and it's they're selling these
you know and a lot of these seminars
that did that whenever the internet
marketing space came around when it
became popularized it was the same idea
it was like oh let's sell these business
and box
at seminars but on the internet it'll be
how to create your website how does you
know drive traffic and i'll join
but are you actually selling an actual
business an actual
product are you selling actual skills
are you teaching people that's
educational has value um and
and that's kind of why i decided you
know this i can't
this is and and jim jim was very um
wise when he said that it was very
seductive it is a seductive industry
because i started in this industry
because i was like one of them too
and i mean not the scammer i'm talking
about the person who bought into the
scams
i was you know the thing is whenever i
first started i was broke
um i was an insurance i was looking at
ways to kind of make myself
get out of my my hole as you know so to
speak and i bought into these products
and all that
and then when i discovered copywriting
and then i decided to do a lot of the
stuff that i've learned that was great
but then when i saw the business
kind of becoming the way it was it's
just it was crazy to me but
anyways so you're actually one of the
people who bought in ironically
and then did get rich from the thing but
in order to get rich you have to bring
more people into the system who are in
all likelihood
not gonna be like that's the whole irony
is in any ponzi scheme or any pyramid
scheme there will be some people who
actually do
achieve the promises of the scheme but
it's always by just getting
enough kind of suckers underneath them i
think it's really bold of you to
come out though and have such a
like sort of 180 going from sort of a
legend of the industry to someone who's
actually very critical of it
what would you say to copywriters who
are looking at the space right now they
want to go work for
you know one of these gigantic firms or
something like this
and they they look up to you know all
these gigantic copywriters who will just
say anything to get this out what would
you say to them
well you just said something right there
to say anything to get the sale
what what is the purpose of the sales
letter what does the purpose of writing
the copy is it just to get the sale
well they're going to say look it's
criminal i've heard this argument
recently
it's it's unethical if you have a good
product not to pitch it as hard as you
humanly can
that's what they i've heard the argument
if you have a great product
it is totally unethical not to pitch it
absolutely to the
to the moon basically anything short of
that
is you're doing your customer a
disservice by not
literally forcing it down their throat
you're out you're doing a disservice
not informing the people that you have
something that can help them
but not shutting it down their throat
that's kind of
counter you know it's not that's not
something that i believe in of course
and
uh that you don't as well but i think
that
for copywriters so the ability to write
a seller the ability to write words that
actually help
sell a product or service is a skill
and and i and i agree that that is a
good skill to have and i think that a
lot of people who are
business owners should learn that skill
uh a business owner
should be like and then i'm talking
about like legitimate businesses that
actually sell products and service let
you know actual products and actual
services
if you need to hire a copyright to help
you because you don't have time or you
ha
you want to give you know you want to
have somebody who's actually skilled in
that area to help you out
that's perfectly fine as well but when
it's all about making a sale rather than
actually serving
the customer because it's really come
down to this are
do people actually do people actually
get value from your product or service
are you actually selling something that
you're making money as a byproduct of
doing something
good that you're serving people with
selling a product or service that
actually does
good that solves a problem um and
and that's the problem with the whole
money making industry because the
problem in this case is they're broke
they want money
which is stupid to me i mean you know so
if you're selling a product or service
that helps people in their businesses
you know
whether it's you do market research
whether it's seo whether it's
a sas tool or software that will help
you
i don't know create a better marketing
automation
process when you're back in those are
legitimate products and services and you
can see you can you can be a good
copywriter that sells those products and
services
but you're solving problems you're
solving real problems and
people who are broken and sick and old
they have
problems that you cannot you know you
cannot solve
that way because you're not really
teaching them actual skills
i mean the best thing i say to people
who are uh copywriters who want to you
know
write for those kinds of companies or
write those kind of products or services
you know how would you sell that to your
mother
would you you know would you take this
letter
and then you know go to your mother and
then try to sell her that product
service
and uh you know if they if they want if
they say yes well then we have a
different problem in our heads
but um it's you why would you do that
to other people's mothers or why would
you do that to people who are in a
situation where
oh but this i can you know i can write a
cop a copy for a sales letter for a
product that will really help them make
a lot of money and get them out of their
hole
okay show me the people who have bought
this product prior to you writing the
copy that i've actually got on their
holes
absolutely and if you and if you can't
if you can't prove that then it's not
really a product that's worth selling or
it's not a product worth writing copy
for
yeah i mean to answer sort of the uh
the question earlier about pushing stuff
down in people's throat is that you
don't have to push
great products down people's throat
exactly people buy exactly
and so they they just you you tell them
about it they go oh great i'll take it
there are all sorts of products like
that out there um like a great example
is tesla who i don't think spends
anything in advertising from what i know
i think they have a zero advertising
budget they use like elon musk's twitter
account basically
and it's one of the biggest automakers
right now why
because or in terms of market cap i
don't know about volume
but uh but why it's just because it's
such an incredible product that it just
does all the selling for itself i mean
you don't really have to
just go sit in one and you're like oh
well this is something if i could afford
it i'll take it
and and if you have a product that
nobody knows about then your job is not
to sell
it's to inform it's to educate it's to
tell people
like to show for example the inner
workings of your product maybe to offer
demos maybe give people a chance to get
a trial maybe to get people an idea of
what
your product actually does rather than
trying to
thrust a you know a a thousand word
uh you know a big long sales letter uh
at a higher price rate you know
i don't know it's just to me it's just
incredible why i think this comes to
comes the actual problem which is a lot
of times when these hypotheticals are
given about this
supposedly great product the problem is
is that the products are
almost universally not great that are
being pitched
they're almost universally kind of shady
which is why they have to be
pitched that way or not as uh effective
as
they say and a lot of the people who
sell these
products today bought products that were
similar like that from other marketers
who brought products like that from
other marketers who bought products like
that from other marketers
it's it's ponzi schemes it's really just
a different
ponzi scheme i guess a lot of these
people are going into this business to
make money
basically you learn how to make money
from other gurus who taught them how to
make money
who learned from other gurus who taught
them how to make money
yeah silly you're not literally like
you're not showing
people actual skills and and how to
create real
businesses you know maybe create a
software product maybe
uh uh create a website that sells uh
you know uh pet cleaning services i
don't know
but the thing is my point though is is
is that a lot of these people are online
right now selling these
quick get rich quick schemes learned it
from other get rich quick schemes
because that's what they teach they
don't they teach they teach thin air
they don't teach
actual businesses they teach people how
to make money
there's a difference between how to you
know teaching people how to create a
business how to make money from that
business rather than
you know i'm gonna i'm gonna you know
teach you how to make money and
basically it's teaching other people how
to make money it's stupid
tell me about uh because you mentioned
free trial get a free trial
free trial we should talk about that
because that's actually one of the the
things they
they offer a lot they offer free trials
with
the forced continuity that you talked
about
explain kind of the the language behind
this if somebody hasn't seen it because
this is
really deceptive stuff um
because to the average person they just
see oh you know for example
maybe they're offering a free book right
but you have to put in your
credit card information oh just for 1.99
shipping or whatever it is
and then all of a sudden you're
subscribed to something that you didn't
know
you were subscribed for how long do
people last on these lists just
getting charged until like not even
knowing
they're getting charged do you know my
well my my
experience with people who do that
usually two or three months
so that's why they have to keep filling
the funnel right they have to keep
finding more people to fill the funnel
so that they can keep it at a certain
level
um and if they use tactics like i was
mentioning earlier about you know
keeping it under
the radar then you probably have six
months or more but
uh sadly enough um the way i look at it
is
offer free trial don't ask for a credit
card and let the person come to their
own conclusion if they actually want to
buy the product or not and uh if you
if you inform them before the trial
expires hey your trial is about to
expire would you like to take advantage
of it here's a special offer
great that's that's that's to me that's
perfectly legitimate
when you buy when you get into a free
trial and you're asking people for a
credit card
and here's the thing too so a lot of
these guys will then sell
a physical product and they were they're
going to ask for
a credit card information because they
said oh it's to pay for the shipping
because i need to ship it to you right
but
you know why would you be able just to
digitize the product and offer
you know as for free in the back end
just ask for you know
so that's a that's telling and b
uh very often um uh people forget and
they
they're often never told about the
expire of their free trials and i've
i've
i've heard stories of people who
literally look you know six months later
they realized that they paid six months
into a product
and then when they approached the uh the
um
the the guru the group would say well
you know you should have known it you
know we had a we had a 30 day guarantee
which is a third day trial
[Music]
so you know you passed your guarantee
time so sorry
um yeah sad sad i i laugh about it it's
i think it's funny because i think
they're deserved but to be laughed at
but
uh i i it's not laughable to think about
the people who are actually
you know mortgaging their houses to buy
this stuff it's just it's yeah it's
incredibly
sad um and and it kind of makes you
angry as well now let me tell you
michael so i i do think
that maybe there's an opportunity for
change in this industry and i'd like to
hear your thoughts about it
um whether you think this industry can
be you know revolutionizes the right
word but
maybe changed even on the margins
because recently
i i made a video about steph and georgie
i don't know if
you saw that video yes
anyway we were going to debate and he
ended up saying you know what
instead of debating i want to i kind of
uh
want to take a second to reflect and he
ended up
i don't want to give away too much from
our private conversation but
he ended up making some pretty
substantial changes in his business i
believe he's selling off
a big chunk of one of his like large
multi-million dollar businesses
because he says he doesn't want to be a
part of that anymore um
or he can't or and he's moving in this
direction he goes you know what
i think i think he'd probably say he's
been thinking about this a long time
i'll take his word for that too um but
he wants to make that change
in the positive direction how does the
copywriting industry as a whole make
that change though
because one person he's a huge
copywriter he's well known
so that's probably a good thing that
someone of his magnitude is making that
kind of a shift
but what would it take for
copywriters at large to make that shift
is it
is it a culture thing is it just like
embedded in the culture
what is it i
i honestly don't know i think that a lot
of the
uh you know copywriters and and the
people that they write copy for
very often it's a cult of personality
right um
and you can you you can try as hard as
you possibly can to change the industry
i mean i've tried
my wife tried uh we've wrote our our
manifestos we've tried we spoke out
against it we you know we've lost a lot
of friends because of coming out
the way we did uh i've lost a lot of
business because of coming out the way i
did
you've probably lost literally millions
of dollars from your choice to get out
of it i would imagine
i would imagine that it would be if you
calculated over the years it would
probably come up to
yeah but
i think it's it's not i i don't want to
look at how much money i've lost because
to me it's it's my sanity and my
ethics and my integrity are probably
more important
they are a hundred percent more
important yeah absolutely um
um and again it's for me it's it's it's
like watching my wife
die in front of me and being taken
advantage of the way she had
and then seeing people even people who
are uh
buying these products and services and
buying into what these gurus are saying
and then seeing them suffer i think
that that's the that's the picture we
need to paint that's the education that
we need to make
uh when we teach other copywriters and
all that not necessarily saying
you know gurus are bad and
yes we knew i think that what you're
doing is a great service and stephen
and and thank you for for being who you
are and doing what you're doing
um but i think that we also need to show
them shine the spotlight on all the
people who are suffering right now the
bankruptcies the
the people are dying the people who are
out in the streets homeless because they
had to remortgage your house and got you
know foreclosed on because they had to
buy group
a b and c's products and services
absolutely um
or showing actual like doing doing these
exposes i mean like for example what
mike when it does which is
you know showing actual interviewing
people who are being scammed like you
you interview people who
who've lost money on your show and how
much money they've invested in how much
of thousands of dollars
those are beautiful those are perfect
because those are really educating
people
these are the people are hurting because
of you these are the people who are
suffering because of you
and i think that if the truly if ethical
people will look at that
like myself and say i don't want to do
this anymore
and that's and the people who don't
you're not
you're not going to be able to change
them because those
they're they're they are who they are
and they'll always be who they are right
you're absolutely right yeah yeah i
think that's right
and i do try to focus on that side of
the industry
um even though it is it's not as
like what's fun about talking about the
gurus is it's very mockable you know
it's very it's
there's a lot of entertainment value in
it but um but there's something
profoundly
like moving and human about
talking to people who have been
basically robbed scammed fleeced
whatever you want to say about it
you know one one person i talked to in
the uh
this future net it was a ponzi scheme uh
they literally knew people on their team
their
downline that had
basically killed killed themselves
um because of what had happened
literally they just had no other
alternative
and this is because they either took out
loans you know from sharks
in the philippines or these are poor
countries but
my when i did that interview i i just
said to myself you know
even though this isn't this may get a
few more people to click off this video
because this
isn't exactly fun it is the most
honest thing i could say about this
industry
and what the actual damage is is it's
not that it's just some
clown making a mockery of himself it's
also that it's like actually harming
people
who have real faces they aren't just
numbers on your conversion sheet right
like i think that's how a lot of uh
people look at it but
yeah i think that's the most important
part the best analogy i can use is my
stepdaughter is vegan
and she's a kind of a she's a bit of a
militant vegan
and she says if you had to
you know raise your cows and your
chickens yourself
and then literally you had to kill them
yourself in order to feed you you and
your family whatever the case
is um and and but you've been you've you
know you're so removed now from that
process you just buy me from the
supermarket
that's why for you it's like it's
nothing you know and so
it's the same thing with these these
copywriters or people who are going into
business for these kinds of reasons
if they knew if they were closer to the
effects of what they're doing
they would probably think twice before
you know either
have a change of heart hopefully um but
like like you said you know there's
going to be people who are going to look
at that and they're going to justify it
in their minds
uh oh yeah you know it's it's it's their
fault
it's because they didn't apply
themselves they didn't try harder
yeah no you're no you're absolutely
right but then they're also going to be
people like steph and georgie who
actually who have a moment of reflection
and they they end up selling off a part
of their business they go a completely
different way
and you are you do have to highlight
those people and you know
you know pay some respect to that so i
also wanted to say thank you
i mean for what you've done where you
really
i didn't say you left a lot of money on
the table to make you you know to make
it seem like oh you should have done
something different
i highlighted it to highlight the fact
that that's
what ethics means you know that's what
being an ethical person means is
doing things the right way it doesn't
necessarily always lead to more riches
but
it leads to uh like you said your sanity
being able to sleep at night you know
and just a general
you return back to the true roots of a
lot of what
you know selling should be about which
is about giving somebody else
value and then you yourself also getting
paid for that
i mean that's like selling at its best
it's marketing
as it at its best is a mutual exchange
of
good my my late wife said the best thing
ever she says don't make money at the
expense of others make money at the
service of others and
unfortunately a lot of these courses
make money at the expense of others
so well said michael well i think uh
i think we've about covered it well
thank you thank you so much michael
appreciate it
oh thank you for everything you do i
know what you mean
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost me wake up and
smell the coffee